[Music]
an inappropriate request new oh that's
me 24/7 submitted by lie in your barn oh
that [ __ ] was hottest never just the
date it was a Justin Bieber remake right
oh yeah yeah those are the days a hotel
worker lost his job after a guest
accuses him of asking for a [ __ ] I
don't believe it isn't it usually the
other way around true is usually the
guests that are demanding yep like can
you change my sheets and give me a
[ __ ] mm-hmm so yeah I never had a
bellboy asked me for a [ __ ] yeah
that's kind of weird good for you guys
so this takes place in Bali oh I thought
Singapore oh you like bond I love
bowling
I want to go picture any of them asking
for a [ __ ] though hmm
what does it do the Indonesian language
sounds insane they're so warm and
welcoming as a culture and spiritual
they're super spiritual like they have
like temples set up everywhere and
everyone's like praying all the time at
them and they got the [ __ ] teeth
shaving a [ __ ] Riley oh this happened at
the Ramada bali and ramadan ramadan
Ramada Ramada Inn
Oh were you kidding everyone I was
kidding
you know I never heard someone pronounce
more exotic than Ramada yeah uncultured
[ __ ] I said it thank you David for
connecting I got your back I'm gonna
start changing if we just start to
change the game everybody called it
Ramadan yeah it sounds like that holiday
Ramadan Ramadan yeah welcome to the
Ramadan anyway so it takes place at that
yeah so what the situation here is that
this woman she was charged in extra
night and apparently it was like through
some miscommunication so she doesn't
really like fully blame the hotel like
she's okay with not getting a refund but
she's trying to figure out how she can
get a refund with this employee here and
so he pulls her aside from the front
desk into like a more intimate area and
then apparently he says like I'll give
you a refund if you give me a [ __ ]
and then she starts after he said that
that's when she started recording on her
cell phone and it was like about that's
horrible so she doesn't even care about
a refund she really doesn't that's why
she's like okay she really wanted it she
would give him a [ __ ] no she wouldn't
anyway so I thought what he was gonna do
is be like uh we could forget about the
refund I thought he was gonna be like
suck my dick but like any she's like oh
my gosh she asked me for a [ __ ] no
I'll show you guys West Coast talk I
know I'll show you guys a video so she
said that a second time right when the
video starts so he says it kind of lows
we gotta catch onto another catch how
does she cook of course she's such a
ninja here we go
I love it
it's difficult because I have a better
our major
it's a market process her bereavement
yeah you know the hotels man yeah I
meant to get a refund from the hotel but
it's too hot but you know I'm married
yeah and you want me to give you a
[ __ ] for me to get the refund doesn't
that seem strange I mean really funny
but it's a good-looking guy what do you
say please do it
I'll give him a [ __ ] please don't
tell what do you think he's begging for
[ __ ] he's begging for her not to
tell on this if not goal and I don't
want to say to say been to any other
customer so yeah I would like to speak
to
please don't how does he not know he's
being recorded there at what there is
because this video is a lot longer it's
just that I showed you guys a shorter
clip of it but in the longer video there
there is this one moment where you could
see him make eye contact at such a
[ __ ] was another word in the endo
Deaton Indonesian language yeah people
are speculating cuz this went viral
people are speculating that instead of a
[ __ ] he was saying a voucher in the
accent it kind of does sound odd to say
like maybe he didn't say [ __ ] maybe
he was saying voucher like you know you
need the voucher or something cuz he
could have said that budget like some I
don't know even if it was voucher it
doesn't make sense in the sentence give
me a voucher like well how am I gonna
give you what it doesn't if you was
asking for like kickback what you know
like kind of like just pay me a little
bit and then I'll handle that'd be so
funny if the person right before him was
[ __ ] around with them because hey if
you want to get money from somebody you
just say [ __ ] it was like a [ __ ] up
American person that'd be whole oh
that's why he was confused because I
don't think that's what it means
because you know if you ask for a
[ __ ] just be confident you look
confident all this is such a weird video
please don't tell about the brow chap
who prays for this - who preys on this
[ __ ] oh that's a bit yeah they're
they're very spiritual there that's why
it almost doesn't make sense to me for
me it feels like it's like a
miscommunication like there's a new word
or he doesn't understand cuz even when
she's like I'm gonna give you a [ __ ]
I'm married his face is like what is
that exactly what does that have to do
I'm asking for handshake I don't
understand what your marriage have to do
with anything
that's the weirdest way to ask for a
[ __ ] that was such a weird video I'll
just take it for face bowing that's such
a that's such a nice request it wasn't a
nice man though can I please don't care
cuz good-looking we're not gonna be like
he's a [ __ ]
I'm so confused about that I'm
glad that it was a better-looking guys I
don't even think that that because
that's slang I don't even think they use
that in volley I mean like that's true
right like maybe when he's speaking to
English customers he knows what if she
starts really like okay and unzipping
his pants he's like no I'm Mary yeah
that she shouldn't that's what she
should have done she should have called
the bluff and see whatever happens she
goes oh you ready for this if you stop
going down hell are you doing
gotcha yeah so it has been confirmed
that he he was asking for a blown fuse
to believe it ended because he's
good-looking that's [ __ ] up no it's
because I think she's a crook that's
[ __ ] up I want to see what she looks
like with Indonesian police say the
Indonesian police that the man admitted
to asking for just been Indonesian first
of all she look from New Zealand
he looks Polynesian as [ __ ] it he would
kill you what a [ __ ] idiot
they're from New Zealand was he thinking
she's pretty brave though she's all like
like what did you say yeah you talked to
a manager I was like oh I would have
been so scared because I would have been
like you want a blow job for me like why
wait what that's the sound scare this
was confused have more confidence in
your girl cell no I might have a few
sanskars I'm not a girl yet I'm a guy oh
it's a guy I be if a guy asked me for a
blow job and he did it that way
I'll be like what you want me to suck
you wouldn't even ask like look at the
size of her husband that fool will punch
through his chest maybe he didn't you
think the husband yeah maybe she was on
a trip with the girls [ __ ] that guy see
her husband because she he would have at
least heard him walk down the hall that
pool is huge that's disgusting
maybe they just do [ __ ] bribes oh how
I've dealt with that situation with this
with his nervous guy in his little eyes
nervous good-looking guy yeah hey
[Music]
anytime I get 500 bucks back what else
are you guys to is like he was telling
her that you would pay her from his own
money
because the hotel it would take a month
to process the refund because it wasn't
the hotel spot so then she was like yeah
I don't mind like not getting the refund
but then what you're asking me to give
you a [ __ ] to get the refund he was
like yeah and I'll pay you out from my
own money to give you the refund so he
was pretty much obstetrician exactly
I'll pay you to give me a [ __ ] the
story at all that guys disgust me I'm
kidding by the way wait he thought she
was a hooker
how do maybe because he has so many
tourists that he sees and he's
good-looking he probably makes these
offers to like white white women that
are married and that's a specific reason
why she she says that she decided to
start filming and even in the video
she's saying this is not okay like how
many more customers like have you
offered this to and like how many your
spirit please get him to admit that in
Indonesia they use whips and cane they
torture you I feel like they're crazy
over there I'd probably waterboard it in
yeah they they like kill you if you have
drugs and stuff yeah they do
yeah he doesn't look threatening to me
so I feel like I kid Bluto yeah like I
can just kind of like talk talk to me be
like what the [ __ ] like you're crazy I
need it yeah
she was really polite I'd be mad yeah
I'd be like what the [ __ ] I was like
immediately I wouldn't even entertain it
I'd be immediately I'm talking to your
superior don't [ __ ] go anywhere I
take a picture of this guy I want to see
you handle a situation cuz for me I've
never seen it not to say that you have
it you won't do it I just want to see it
well I've handled a lot of situations
other I feel because I would just be in
the bat'leth like if someone is trying
to make me dumb or like try to pull fast
and it just pisses me off
yeah one time [ __ ] eyebrows I was
dragging meatloaf across someone's lawn
she started getting going in with that
guy cuts her me out a little bit that's
something that I just never seen it go
yell out is that you were dragging
meatloaf across someone's lungs claiming
so what happened so our dog likes to
pool like crazy right so he's pulling
and he like your dog's name is meatloaf
that's so [ __ ] random his name are
Bay yeah okay well then yeah that's more
like because I was like it kind of
believed the neighbor if they're gonna
make a claim that [ __ ] is with this
interracial couple dragging a piece of
meatloaf on my life yeah how do you like
but you had to cook that the woman in
the video though that was kind of like
she was telling him like I'm fighting
the urge to scream at you and slap at
you right now
yeah she's very self control I can't I
can't be I wouldn't be at I'd be so
enraged I wouldn't be asking how many
other women how many whatever I'd be
like there's a problem right now that's
with me I need to fix this [ __ ] right
and that's why he doesn't ask ethnic
women we asked what we were in Bali
because we're on a double honeymoon and
the other girl Jess she's also an
Islander ethnic girl and we were talking
about how we're kind of crazy you know
like we're a little bit crazy but you
know guys like it so whatever and then
I'm like I'm pretty sure all at least
all ethnic women are crazy and then so
we asked what the the waiter that came
over we're like are you married he's
like yeah and like is your wife crazy
she he's like have you have you talked
to her recently you scared you like you
hurt branch yeah because because I just
I swear to god he starts getting scared
like watching me right now I don't think
we would keep our composure being asked
to pose oh I'd be so confused and then
like you like if I fine
because her grip is very strong and I
don't know what to do when she grabs my
wrist to cover the bruises yeah it's
very tender hey you are you married he's
like yes
is your wife crazy no no no absolutely
right here yeah what have you heard I
love her he like looks like she's over
there oh no no no I love her better
freaking out no why would you ask no
walking usually a chain on his ankle
right now she's going to [ __ ] you up
just a red light now
[Music]